No.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Uh, no, it hasn't been set yet.
Thank you, but I gotta work that out.
NOTE CONF
Um, so turn the light off.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Um yeah.
NOTE CONF
So let's think about that.
Simon's Jew.
NOTE CONF
Not this week, but next week.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Um, this Sunday.
Ok, All right.
NOTE CONF
Oh, so we gotta do one either thursday or Friday.
Ok?
NOTE CONF
Alright.
I'll get one booked today for Thursday or Fri, I
NOTE CONF
guess Friday's the best day, obviously.
Um, let's just double check all that.
NOTE CONF
OK, So, um 3000.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Ah, yeah.
I was mixing up with the comp 2001.
NOTE CONF
Ok, uh, I'll just send that email off now.
Okey dokey.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Is anything coming up?
NOTE CONF
Uh, things are slowly coming up that's available.
Hello, people online.
NOTE CONF
If there are any of you, can I see how
many are online at one time?
NOTE CONF
I don't know that I can.
Okey dokey.
NOTE CONF
Any questions?
I got one question before I get started.
NOTE CONF
Which was when's our test are done?
I just fired off an email to Cameron.
NOTE CONF
I gotta book it in.
I wanna try and book it in the drop in
NOTE CONF
centre room, so I just gotta make sure there's time
available, but the plan would be sometime on Friday because
NOTE CONF
that's the most sensible.
Obviously, there's only Thursday and Friday left after today.
NOTE CONF
So it's gonna be one of those two days, But
a plan for Friday afternoon?
NOTE CONF
Um, I'm always, uh, free to deal with students from
about three o'clock on a Friday afternoon anyway.
NOTE CONF
But often that's my honours student.
So maybe we can do it with the honours students.
NOTE CONF
I don't know, but it's just about getting a venue
sorted to do it.
NOTE CONF
Um, so maybe we should just say Friday afternoon and
we're trying to work out a venue to set the
NOTE CONF
time.
But, I mean, it's fairly simple stuff.
NOTE CONF
It it It's fairly simple.
If the if the compilation steps work, then you've done
NOTE CONF
it, right?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
This is for the assignment, which is due next week.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, assignment due on Sunday.
We're testing a thon.
NOTE CONF
As in testing that your submissions work?
Yeah, OK.
NOTE CONF
And then after that, the past exam becomes available on
Monday morning for a full week for you to have
NOTE CONF
a go at the first exam.
And then if you get higher than 77% on that,
NOTE CONF
which you should, because you have three attempts and it's
really easy.
NOTE CONF
Then you'll be able to come and sit the distinction
exam in the first week of the break at a
NOTE CONF
time that you pick from a set of scheduled times.
That exam is optional.
NOTE CONF
Well, every exam is optional, and there's no hurdles in
this class.
NOTE CONF
You get over 50% and you're good to go.
Ah, but the course is designed so that every student
NOTE CONF
should attempt every assignment and every pass exam, but that
not every student will choose to sit every distinction exam.
NOTE CONF
If they're just going for a pass grade and they're
happy, they don't have to be there.
NOTE CONF
Um, uh, obviously, we encourage you to be there because
more marks are about a Yes, well, we got two
NOTE CONF
overall exams, but each exam is split in two parts,
and the two parts are the pass part, and the
NOTE CONF
distinction part pass parts take home do multiple times easy.
The distinction part is turn up, sit in an exam,
NOTE CONF
do it one time harder, and so they're currently scheduled
for next week for the past part.
NOTE CONF
The week after for distinction And then at the end
of semester, we've got another round of exactly the same
NOTE CONF
setup, which is scheduled for a week, 13 for the
past part and then the first week of the exam
NOTE CONF
period for the distinction part so effectively got a mid
semester exam block and a final exam block.
NOTE CONF
Both of them split into those two parts.
OK, any other questions?
NOTE CONF
I expect there will be a few, because it's not
the simplest thing.
NOTE CONF
I mean, we do it in a fair number of
courses, but you would never have done it this way
NOTE CONF
before.
Yeah, um, so if you for, uh, I on the
NOTE CONF
next week, Yeah.
Um And what happens then?
NOTE CONF
Like, um, do you get how many percent do you
get that?
NOTE CONF
And if you do the next one after that, uh,
do you get like or what is it?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So the first part of the mid semester, the take
NOTE CONF
home part is worth 65 percent of that exam.
So that's why we call it a pass part and
NOTE CONF
a distinction part 65% out of the take home part,
35% out of the turn up part.
NOTE CONF
So If you get 100% on the take home part,
you've got 65 out of 100 for that for that
NOTE CONF
exam.
If you get 77% on the Tamp part, you've got
NOTE CONF
50% on that exam.
And then it goes on to and on this one
NOTE CONF
Connect.
Right.
NOTE CONF
So maybe I drew a diagram to help make it
a bit.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I know it's not that.
Let's make it clearer.
NOTE CONF
Right?
So Oops.
NOTE CONF
Vision like that.
Diagrams make everything better.
NOTE CONF
That's one of the themes of today's lecture Diagrams.
Make everything better.
NOTE CONF
Um, come on.
Are you doing anything?
NOTE CONF
No, You gotta turn on.
No, but turn that off.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
I turn that off.
NOTE CONF
Keep turning the light on.
Well, that's ugly.
NOTE CONF
So income 3000.
The exams are split into two parts mid sem and
NOTE CONF
the final.
Yeah, Actually, I should have done it differently.
NOTE CONF
I'll do it again.
So we got the midterms coming up and every exam
NOTE CONF
is split into two parts as well.
Yeah, well, you can see.
NOTE CONF
OK, Jesus.
What's going on with this thing?
NOTE CONF
OK, that's better.
So two exams midterm final Both were the same percentage
NOTE CONF
each exam split in two two parts.
So ultimately, there's four things we're doing.
NOTE CONF
This one over here is called the Pass Exam.
It's take time at home and you get multiple chances.
NOTE CONF
Three of them.
This one's called the Distinction exam, and it's in.
NOTE CONF
You gotta turn up for it like an old school
exam.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
You get one chance at it.
NOTE CONF
You turn up, do it in our labs.
It's still on the computers, but it's in person, same
NOTE CONF
again here.
And then this one here is potentially optional.
NOTE CONF
You you choose whether you wanna sit there or not,
and you actually only get access to it if you
NOTE CONF
did better than 77% on the first one.
So people who don't even get 77% on the first
NOTE CONF
one we're not even gonna bother giving you the chance
to turn up to the distinction exam because you're clearly
NOTE CONF
phoning it in because it's three chances at home.
OK, um yeah, and that fine.
NOTE CONF
And that's also yeah, yeah, both of them run exactly
the same way.
NOTE CONF
So that's at home this part Times three, and that's
old school as well.
NOTE CONF
And the how how different is the content from life
the only difficult.
NOTE CONF
The only changes are in difficulty and question style, not
in content.
NOTE CONF
They both cover the same content.
So everything we can one of the reasons we do
NOTE CONF
this is everything we can.
Auto Mark goes in the past section so that you
NOTE CONF
can do multiple attempts.
We like multiple attempts, everything we can't auto.
NOTE CONF
Mark goes in the distinction section, and we have to
restrict you to one attempt because otherwise we can't get
NOTE CONF
the marking done.
So think of it more of that way.
NOTE CONF
But the distinction ones are definitely harder than the past
ones.
NOTE CONF
You'll find all the easy questions in the past section
and all the difficult questions now, but it will be
NOTE CONF
the same content.
And for us, that's up until, um, we went all
NOTE CONF
the way to I said it in the practise exam,
right?
NOTE CONF
Or did I not say exactly which weeks I put
up something on the practise exam just to make sure
NOTE CONF
I'm saying the right thing?
Well, I didn't pronounce something on it, did I?
NOTE CONF
Maybe I didn't put it out yet, OK?
No, I haven't put that out yet, so I can
NOTE CONF
remind myself we're looking over here at exactly which weeks?
Uh, which one through six.
NOTE CONF
So the exam doesn't include this week material, but includes
everything else.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
You know, this is all the way to the final,
NOTE CONF
uh, the final period because it says X and a
60% of the way.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Uh, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So overall, this one's worth.
These two together are worth 30 percent of your final
NOTE CONF
grade, and these two together are worth 30 percent of
your final grade.
NOTE CONF
And, um, if you get like, I if you get
one on the best, uh, the mitre do you get
NOTE CONF
the 30% then or do you have to do the
the station?
NOTE CONF
Now you have to see that.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So if you score full marks on this, you'll end
up with whatever.
NOTE CONF
65% of 30% is added to your final grade.
Um, but I expect quite a few people will be
NOTE CONF
in that situation.
They'll happily get full marks in the past.
NOTE CONF
And I'll be I saved myself from having to worry
about that distinguishing exam.
NOTE CONF
Fine.
C.
NOTE CONF
So not the simplest, but not the most complex either.
And I hope you can.
NOTE CONF
Well, maybe you can't.
Some of you probably can in intuitively understand why we
NOTE CONF
might do it that way.
Um, this is us trying to mix and match the
NOTE CONF
best of all the different teaching and learning and assessment
styles.
NOTE CONF
Giving you a chance to sit an exam multiple times
is definitely beneficial to you, not just for getting your
NOTE CONF
grades up, but also sitting an exam and practising the
questions is a really good way to learn.
NOTE CONF
So that past exam actually becomes a bit of a
learning experience as well as an assessing experience, but at
NOTE CONF
the same time to sort the wheat from the chaff.
We better have some assessment that's in person where you
NOTE CONF
can't muck about, Um and I mean, you're not allowed
to work in groups.
NOTE CONF
When you do the past exam, you've got to submit
your own work and nobody else's work.
NOTE CONF
But of course, it's very hard for us to, um,
police that.
NOTE CONF
So we've got a section where we know for sure
nobody's mucking about and cheating and jumping on discord and
NOTE CONF
talking to their mates.
Which, by the way, uh, regardless of the difficulty of
NOTE CONF
um, policing is a breach of academic integrity.
When you're sitting an exam and when you're submitting work,
NOTE CONF
you're submitting your work.
If you're in a discord chat, chatting to other people
NOTE CONF
about the questions, you it's impossible to be submitting your
own work.
NOTE CONF
And at that level, it's a I'll bring you back
in integrity.
NOTE CONF
OK, so open book doesn't mean open slather.
It just means you have access to other nonhumans to
NOTE CONF
help you.
But you do not have access to other humans to
NOTE CONF
help you making sense.
Making sense.
NOTE CONF
All right?
No.
NOTE CONF
So the exam one practise question link is not the
actual past exam.
NOTE CONF
It's a chance for you to do it infinitely many
times.
NOTE CONF
If someone's been studying hard, they've probably seen all the
questions I've put in there by now.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I think there's 2530 questions or something.
Uh, but it'll just show you five randomly at a
NOTE CONF
time, and you can do it over and over again
to get through all of our practise questions and no,
NOTE CONF
a whole another one will appear, which will say Exam
one pass questions and that will have a five day
NOTE CONF
limit cos it'll open on Monday after your exam after
your assignment finishes and it'll close on the following Friday.
NOTE CONF
So it's open for those five days and it's got
a It's got a set time out on it.
NOTE CONF
I think it's 20 minutes is the max you can.
So once you open it, you've got 20 minutes to
NOTE CONF
submit it or you time out on your 10 and
it takes the highest of those three grades.
NOTE CONF
The practise questions do include examples of the type of
questions you'll see in the distinction and the past exam.
NOTE CONF
Yes, the practise questions actually include again.
You should think of it as the questions of style
NOTE CONF
differently again in the practise questions, Um, the topics are
the same.
NOTE CONF
The concepts are the same, but the style of question
won't necessarily line up exactly.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK, Uh, what I mean by picking any time
to do that distinction exam is that at the moment
NOTE CONF
you've gotten over 77% on the past exam.
A new link will appear on I learn, which will
NOTE CONF
have a set of exam times for you to choose
from.
NOTE CONF
You self enrol into one of those exam times.
So, for example, if we look at the calendar.
NOTE CONF
This is my calendar.
Ignore this.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we've got This is your week, the green
the week that I've got outreach activities so you'll submit.
NOTE CONF
You'll have you'll see in the self enrolment slots open
on some of these days at different times.
NOTE CONF
16th, 17th day.
Not every one of those days.
NOTE CONF
Not every time, Right, But we'll try and have some
evening times.
NOTE CONF
We'll try and have some day times.
We'll try and have some at the start of the
NOTE CONF
week.
Try and have some at the end of the week
NOTE CONF
and you'll see a link up here where you then
can pick the time you're gonna turn up for your.
NOTE CONF
It's only a half hour block to do the distinction
exam, and we just do it in the labs during
NOTE CONF
the holiday period.
So if you're going away for that entire first week,
NOTE CONF
you're in trouble.
But as long as you're ho uh around in Sydney
NOTE CONF
for some part of that, well, not in massive trouble,
you can just not sit the distinction.
NOTE CONF
It's up to you, or you can chase the special
consideration and all that kind of stuff, but, uh, there
NOTE CONF
should be somewhere in that for those five days.
Something you can do?
NOTE CONF
Uh, OK.
And yeah, I made a mistake of not clearly announcing
NOTE CONF
that at the start of one of the previous semesters,
Whereas we were very clear.
NOTE CONF
First week of exam period, first week of mid semester
break.
NOTE CONF
Um, things are going on.
Oh, no, it wasn't that clear.
NOTE CONF
This is the one where I made a slight mistake
on the dates.
NOTE CONF
If I made a slight mistake, you got a better
chance of getting a, uh, special consideration, OK, other questions?
NOTE CONF
No.
OK, the next admin thing was to say that I'm
NOTE CONF
planning on slowing the course down a little bit.
So I think we told you that this is the
NOTE CONF
first time we've run the course in this style and
we planned out our list of topics.
NOTE CONF
Um, you learn a little bit as you go, and
it's better to be flexible than rigid.
NOTE CONF
Uh, one of the things we've realised is that we
could actually get away with not teaching classes and inheritance
NOTE CONF
if we change the way we approach some of the
other topics.
NOTE CONF
The other thing we've learned is that the conceptual overhead
here is you can nod or shake if I'm if
NOTE CONF
I'm right or wrong.
But the conceptual overhead of this code base is a
NOTE CONF
bit higher than we might have expected.
And people are spending more time and energy getting into
NOTE CONF
the code base.
So the plan, well, that's not official yet.
NOTE CONF
But the plan is to, um, not cover classes and
inheritance and to spread this week statements and state over
NOTE CONF
two weeks and spread.
I think its functions over two weeks.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we still have the exact same number of
weeks.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but it's two less topics from the main text
and just the same topics from the, um, seven languages
NOTE CONF
text.
And we can I can tell you ahead of time
NOTE CONF
that for all of the seven language topics, we'll just
do the intro on day one of every language.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so that I think I'm comfortable with is the
right amount of material for you to be able to
NOTE CONF
get into that allows us to cover all the learning
outcomes so on and so forth.
NOTE CONF
OK, so you have a chance now, cos it's not
official yet.
NOTE CONF
I haven't put out an announcement or anything you have
a chance now to have your say about that.
NOTE CONF
You can give me your feedback about that as an
idea, either now or or privately.
NOTE CONF
That's fine.
Uh, because we advertise that classes or inheritance were gonna
NOTE CONF
be in there as a part of making sure we
deliver everything we advertise.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we will also schedule a session for anyone who
wants to turn up and talk to Damien and I
NOTE CONF
about classes and inheritance.
Um, if you signed up to the course and that
NOTE CONF
was the thing you're most looking forward to, there'll still
be a chance to learn it with Damien and I.
NOTE CONF
But it'll be taken out of the assessments.
It'll be taken out of the weekly lectures.
NOTE CONF
It'll be taken out of the workshops.
We'll instead do that as just a kind of optional
NOTE CONF
seminar at the end, where those interested students can sit
and chat about, um, classes and inheritance.
NOTE CONF
We're actually planning to do that anyway, because the course
is set up so that on everything, you've got an
NOTE CONF
expansion opportunity.
We're only doing day one of each of the seven
NOTE CONF
languages because you can choose to do Day two or
day three.
NOTE CONF
And we're only doing the first half of the crafting
interpreters book cos you might choose to go do the
NOTE CONF
second half.
It's very clear to you what your next steps are
NOTE CONF
if this turns out to be an interesting subject for
you.
NOTE CONF
So we're always planning to do a seminar at the
end where we said, Just turn up and let's talk
NOTE CONF
about some of these extension topics just for fun.
Anyone who's interested.
NOTE CONF
Um, but now that will include those two topics.
If we end up going down this route Yep.
NOTE CONF
Questions.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So the several languages thing that applies, um to Oh,
no, the the past language is where we did more
NOTE CONF
than one day.
I think in Ruby, we did one and two.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Then that stays with one and two.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I think for well, certainly for prologue and
again for Scala next week, we'll just be doing day
NOTE CONF
one.
Uh, OK.
NOTE CONF
And it was Scarlet Day.
One is a big day one.
NOTE CONF
That's what convinced me I should just stick with this
approach.
NOTE CONF
And it actually fits really nicely because you just get
just that material.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the other change we did this year is, we
added, assessing the seven languages to the course.
NOTE CONF
We used to have a language of the week that
was not assessed, and it was the most popular part
NOTE CONF
of the course and then not assessed, which was a
bit weird.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so the balance of working out exactly which part
of the seven languages to do is working out which
NOTE CONF
having accessible parts as well are parts that relate to
the learning outcome, not just randomly picking a small amount
NOTE CONF
from each language.
Yeah, but that works out.
NOTE CONF
We've been through and double checked everything.
We'll be able to make it work with all the
NOTE CONF
day ones.
The about cos each chapter says Tiny paragraph, then about
NOTE CONF
then day one.
And that's good.
NOTE CONF
But Scarlet's next week.
Not this week.
NOTE CONF
These are all a little bit out.
As you've noticed, the seven languages are one week out.
NOTE CONF
Um, we cover Scarlet next week.
You know more than enough to do this week with,
NOTE CONF
um, the first part of statements in state.
So I put it up here.
NOTE CONF
So now when you see the readings Oops, don't wanna
go back now.
NOTE CONF
When you see the readings, you'll see, it's being explicit
about which sections we need to cover.
NOTE CONF
So we're doing sections 8.1 and 8.2 of that book
and on week eight, which we haven't quite finished filling
NOTE CONF
in.
But it's, uh, the rest of crafting interpreters.
NOTE CONF
And then Scala, uh, I'm gonna do that today so
it can be released early.
NOTE CONF
And yes, everybody who is saying Please release the readings
a bit earlier.
NOTE CONF
Yep, I'm gonna try and do.
I'm just trying to try and get them all out
NOTE CONF
now now that we know for sure.
And this explanation might explain to you why we were
NOTE CONF
releasing things this week at a time.
Because first time you run a course, Um, you've gotta
NOTE CONF
be flexible.
You've gotta be flexible to the student's experience of what's
NOTE CONF
going on.
You can't just bloat the co course out and then
NOTE CONF
run it as it is.
Otherwise, you might end up with a a pile of
NOTE CONF
overwhelmed students struggling to, um, learn the materials.
OK, good, good.
NOTE CONF
That's all the admin.
Let's do some actual statements and state.
NOTE CONF
So I said early on, I said earlier that part
of this week's focus is just coming to understand this
NOTE CONF
code base.
Um, that's actually a key.
NOTE CONF
I should probably put that in as a key learning
outcome.
NOTE CONF
Being a programming language person understanding programming languages is the
same thing as understanding at least one compiler.
NOTE CONF
Really Well, especially when that one compiler or interpreter is
this one where the various opportunities are explored just at
NOTE CONF
the edges of what's going on.
So for a little while, at least a week and
NOTE CONF
a bit at least two weeks this week and next
week, I just want you to think of your main
NOTE CONF
job as just being.
I really gotta understand this code base front to back
NOTE CONF
and what goes on in what places.
You should be starting to feel that now because we
NOTE CONF
told you to put new syntactic forms in, and we
asked you to scan them and parse them.
NOTE CONF
But it should be obvious to you.
The very next thing we're gonna do is to ask
NOTE CONF
you to put in something and scan it and parse
it and interpret it.
NOTE CONF
And so you're going to have to really know how
the interpreter goes together and where to put all the
NOTE CONF
parts.
And because we've got the end to end interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Now we've got scanning, parsing, interpreting, putting the output.
We can see its whole and it gets more complex,
NOTE CONF
as opposed to gritting more files.
We've got a couple of new files up here.
NOTE CONF
Ah, but you get the point.
Uh, next week we add in an environment file.
NOTE CONF
So we're holding off on that this week.
That was gonna be in this week.
NOTE CONF
Um, but this week we do add statements which weren't
there before, but I really feel that you're gonna be
NOTE CONF
lost as to what the heck's even going on from
here on in.
NOTE CONF
If you're not understanding the whole of the compiler how
it hangs together so spend time and energy and spend
NOTE CONF
your your interactions with the staff on coming to understand
how the system goes together and draw lots of diagrams.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna draw more diagrams.
You're gonna draw more diagrams.
NOTE CONF
Nobody's sharing their diagrams on the forum.
So start doing that because that's a super valuable way
NOTE CONF
to do things.
Alright, but let's go through statement of the material, OK?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So right from the start, we learnt that the lock
NOTE CONF
we we learnt the entirety of the lock language.
But we've now abandoned most of the locks language and
NOTE CONF
just been doing expressions, and they just went in one
line.
NOTE CONF
So all of the examples I was able to give
you the example.
NOTE CONF
Programmes were just single lines, and I think it was
the same in the assignment, right?
NOTE CONF
The example.
Programmes I gave you were just single line programmes cos
NOTE CONF
they were just a single expression.
Obviously, that's not a programming language.
NOTE CONF
He says it here.
It's just a calculator.
NOTE CONF
So this distinction between expressions and statements is key.
Expressions evaluate to a value, so they really are just
NOTE CONF
like a calculator.
Statements are actions or commands for the computer to do
NOTE CONF
where one command up here might affect another command down
here.
NOTE CONF
And so the order in which they operate matters as
well.
NOTE CONF
So we're just stepping up to statements, and it's a
nice mix to be able to say Look, expressions tend
NOTE CONF
to fit on one line, and statements tend to go
down lines like you need a whole line for a
NOTE CONF
statement, but you might only need a part of a
line for an expression, and you can build up expressions
NOTE CONF
into other other expressions by combining them.
You can't really combine statements by any other statements in
NOTE CONF
them.
Um, yeah, but maybe you can.
NOTE CONF
So we're just gonna look at some.
We're looking at a few statements to get us started.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna look at the print statement, and we're gonna
look at variable declarations.
NOTE CONF
Uh, there's other statements in this language.
There's loops and well control flow, which comes later.
NOTE CONF
There are what other statements are they?
Well, we're not putting.
NOTE CONF
We have no variables in this language.
At this point, we're adding variables, but only in declarations.
NOTE CONF
We're not adding variable uses yet We're doing that because
we need the environments to do variable uses.
NOTE CONF
And we're holding off on that till next week.
So we're kind of just doing the machinery of getting
NOTE CONF
statements into a system that's already there.
What does it mean for our existing system to put
NOTE CONF
statements in there?
It talks about side effects, and that's a good way
NOTE CONF
to think of statements.
Good way to think that expressions generally don't affect anything
NOTE CONF
except the value that they end up being calculated as
where statements can have effects that exist beyond the statement.
NOTE CONF
A variable declaration obviously has an ex effect.
It creates a new variable that you can use later
NOTE CONF
on.
Print has an effect.
NOTE CONF
Something appears on the screen that's gonna stay there.
It's not going anywhere.
NOTE CONF
Um, so that thing is called the side effect.
And many statements exist just for their side effect.
NOTE CONF
So an assignment statement has a side effect that a
slot over there in memory gets changed.
NOTE CONF
It's another nice way to think of the distinction between
expressions and statements, although with all these things there are
NOTE CONF
subtleties.
But we we can go with that.
NOTE CONF
The first thing we introduced is just a special kind
of statement.
NOTE CONF
This is nothing but an expression.
We already had this in the language.
NOTE CONF
We were prepared to write things like, Let me bring
up her locks.
NOTE CONF
Interpreter of some variety.
What should I do?
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll do it in.
It's just gonna open a big uh, it's in the
NOTE CONF
one drive somewhere.
No, that one.
NOTE CONF
Drive.
Where's my other one?
NOTE CONF
Drive.
Uh, come on, Apple have changed.
NOTE CONF
How long you've gotta hold down on something before it
gets copied and it's driving me crazy.
NOTE CONF
Let's do Oh, I thought I might show you something
else as well.
NOTE CONF
Which is how I'm organising my, um, various interpreters.
So an interpreter is an entire directory, and we're often
NOTE CONF
making changes to interpreters.
Uh, and the change in one place might want to
NOTE CONF
be carried over to another place.
It might not.
NOTE CONF
I think it's probably useful to see how I've organised
mine.
NOTE CONF
So let's do that.
Um, What is going on there?
NOTE CONF
No.
Oh, it's already in the tree view.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we need to go into that one, and
we need to go into this one.
NOTE CONF
OK, so here's where I'm storing.
Can I make this bigger?
NOTE CONF
OK, yeah, it only goes one bigger.
Here's where I'm storing.
NOTE CONF
Um, all the code for the course.
And I've got lots and lots of versions of the
NOTE CONF
interpreter.
I got my version.
NOTE CONF
I've got the example meta programming.
I did.
NOTE CONF
I've got one where I tried out coffee orders to
see if that was a good assignment or not.
NOTE CONF
Um, there's the block coms we did earlier.
I've got a copy of the full repository from, uh,
NOTE CONF
the textbook.
But the main useful thing I think I've got for
NOTE CONF
you guys is that I've got a week's directory and
I have a new copy of the interpreter representing what
NOTE CONF
the interpreter looks like at the end of that week
of the course.
NOTE CONF
So if I go into week five, I'll see exactly
the interpreter, as the book described it at the end
NOTE CONF
of week five, and then I can copy that entire
directory over somewhere if I wanted a fresh version.
NOTE CONF
OK, I wanna base this work on week five that's
gonna copy my Week five directory and boom.
NOTE CONF
Now I got a brand new interpreter, and off I
go one problem with that.
NOTE CONF
What's the problem with that?
Let's have a look.
NOTE CONF
If I were to copy, say the powers are from
week five and just copy it over to another directory,
NOTE CONF
um, the package wouldn't line up anymore.
So I also have a a, um, find and replace
NOTE CONF
that, uh, when I copy it over to a new
directory, I got a built in find and replace.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, looks like Oh, that syntax, we fire.
Oh, I went to the wrong director.
NOTE CONF
Um, that finds every one of those packages and just
converts it into the the new package name that I
NOTE CONF
need.
And so those two, those two instructions Just copy an
NOTE CONF
entire directory over and then just find and replace every
package line.
NOTE CONF
It also has to find and replace the import static
as well.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I actually find and replace just that, and
then it finds them all, um, does the job for
NOTE CONF
me and I get a fresh copy and off I
go again.
NOTE CONF
I can do some experimenting.
And so that's what I was.
NOTE CONF
It's That's what I'm trying to prompt you towards for
this assignment where I said it should start off the
NOTE CONF
week five code and some people said, Can you please
send me a copy of the Week five Code?
NOTE CONF
No, I want you to copy and paste at least
your own version of the week five code from the
NOTE CONF
text.
I don't want you just to download the final code,
NOTE CONF
which would be Week 13 and then work off that
I want you to actually go through line by line.
NOTE CONF
Drag and drop.
Make your own, compile it, find the errors, fix them.
NOTE CONF
That's not just busy work that's learning work.
But once I've done that for Week five, I want
NOTE CONF
to be able to copy and and experiment with things
for the workshops and experiment things for the assignments.
NOTE CONF
And so that's my way of making different ones and
keeping them separate.
NOTE CONF
So they're all separate over here, and they all compile
and run with different jac or java lines just by
NOTE CONF
being in different packages.
Uh, so the reason to show you that is because
NOTE CONF
over here I'm now just gonna, uh, run the result
of week seven.
NOTE CONF
And to do that, my Jabba is go to the
Weeks directory, go to the seven directory.
NOTE CONF
Um, I've actually already run the a ST generator, so
that's OK.
NOTE CONF
Start at Java.
Oops, that java not Jac.
NOTE CONF
And that was je yeah and then Java.
And I just discovered a trick.
NOTE CONF
You can put slashes instead of dots in you.
Did you already know that?
NOTE CONF
So it's strictly in Java land.
I need to tell it.
NOTE CONF
I want it to run the locks main class from
the seven package and the weeks package.
NOTE CONF
And this is the syntax for packages in Java.
But when I do that, the command line tab trick
NOTE CONF
I have that finishes off my so I'll do it
again so you can see command line.
NOTE CONF
People are really used to being able to just put
the first couple of letters and press tab and it
NOTE CONF
fills in the rest.
And then I put the first couple of letters in
NOTE CONF
Tab and it fills in the rest, but it automatically
fills it in with the Slash because it thinks I'm
NOTE CONF
talking about directories.
But the cool thing Java supports that it just converts
NOTE CONF
the slashes to dots.
Ah, makes my life much easier.
NOTE CONF
Alright, so here's the week seven locks up and running.
All of that was to get to the point where
NOTE CONF
I wanted to be able to say we were doing
five plus three just putting expressions in before.
NOTE CONF
But we're moving to statements.
That's not OK anymore.
NOTE CONF
Every, um, locks statement has to finish with a semicolon,
but this is actually a perfectly valid locks statement.
NOTE CONF
It's just a statement that calculates something and throws away
the answer kind of pointless except for our testing.
NOTE CONF
So that's a special kind of statement called an expression
statement.
NOTE CONF
All it does is contain an expression, but the term
is is lift it from expression into statement by putting
NOTE CONF
a semicolon there.
The next kind of statement I definitely wanna support is
NOTE CONF
print.
OK, And the other type of statement I want to
NOTE CONF
support at this point is just the variable declaration which,
if I recall, was a V.
NOTE CONF
Have I got the right words?
So there were two forms.
NOTE CONF
There was one where we just did the variable declaration.
And there was one where we did the declaration and
NOTE CONF
gave it an initial value.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Those are the four things I want to support.
First one's called an expression statement.
NOTE CONF
Second one's called a print statement.
Third one's called a declaration statement or a variable declaration
NOTE CONF
statement, but they're the three different types of statements I've
got.
NOTE CONF
So that's the first thing I need to do when
I've got something new that needs to be.
NOTE CONF
Well, this thing doesn't need to be scanned.
Our scanner is already set up to run these things.
NOTE CONF
We set out scanner with all the tokens.
It was good, but our pas is not passing this
NOTE CONF
yet, So he, uh, this part of the text, he
only talks about expression and print.
NOTE CONF
And then I'm just gonna I'm gonna give you a
little preview.
NOTE CONF
And then he goes how to execute the those two
types of statements.
NOTE CONF
And then he goes into how to do a variable
declaration.
NOTE CONF
And that's where we start.
So he does the full thing for expressions and print,
NOTE CONF
and then he does just the passing part for variable
declarations.
NOTE CONF
Um, but you and I are gonna put in the
interpreter for variable declarations in our workshops.
NOTE CONF
In a empty version, we're gonna stub them out with
just something of emptiness.
NOTE CONF
But you'll see what I mean by let me get
through as we get through Kos.
NOTE CONF
So the first thing we gotta do is add these
three to our, um grandma.
NOTE CONF
So I think I've done that.
Here he goes through the explanation of how he does
NOTE CONF
it.
Nope, that's not where it is.
NOTE CONF
I'm in five.
That's why.
NOTE CONF
So I got seven as a shadow.
So I've been keeping the, um, the grammar at the
NOTE CONF
top of my pars that help me keep track of
what each version is doing.
NOTE CONF
So one key change is that the top of a,
uh, cool I can jump back and forth that on
NOTE CONF
the old one, the top of the Parsa was an
expression cos that was all we knew how to pause
NOTE CONF
and we went straight into the precedence discussion, uh, where
we did the low precedence things first down to the
NOTE CONF
highest precedence things to make sure that the pas are
grouped everything together.
NOTE CONF
But really, the top of a programme is a pro.
Uh, a programme is actually a list of statements and
NOTE CONF
then an end of file at the end.
So that's all we really want our pasa to accept
NOTE CONF
now a list of statements with an end of file
at the end.
NOTE CONF
And we've got the three possible types of statements that
could go in here.
NOTE CONF
We've got the variable declarations statement, the expression statement or
the print statement.
NOTE CONF
So it could be any one of those three, but
only those three.
NOTE CONF
So we just need to define what each of those
three are in.
NOTE CONF
The grammar expression statements.
Nice and easy.
NOTE CONF
It's exactly an expression with a semicolon at the end.
And you saw that in action where my grandma Oh,
NOTE CONF
sorry.
My positive did no longer accept it without the, um
NOTE CONF
without the semicolon.
A print statement is just print followed by expression followed
NOTE CONF
by semicolon.
Very easy, and a variable declaration is the one that's
NOTE CONF
a little bit more complicated.
It's the variable keyword, then some kind of identifier which
NOTE CONF
our scanner already knows how to do for us and
then optionally the assignment.
NOTE CONF
And because that's optional, we put it in the parentheses.
In the grammar.
NOTE CONF
Those parentheses don't exist in the code.
Those parentheses are from the grammar, uh, with a question
NOTE CONF
mark after cos that says you might choose to have
an equals expression or you might choose not to, But
NOTE CONF
you're definitely gonna have a cynical and then we're gonna
work out.
NOTE CONF
What?
What does it look like when you're passing these?
NOTE CONF
Um, we can follow the same rules from the PSA
as before.
NOTE CONF
We've already we already know how to pass one thing,
then another.
NOTE CONF
We already know how to choose between alternatives, but let's
be explicit about it in our puzzle.
NOTE CONF
So the programme one's gonna be fairly easy.
It's gonna be We said that when we've got multiples
NOTE CONF
of something, we we loop over it and grab them
all and put them into a list.
NOTE CONF
So we'll do that when we've got optionals.
We use if statements to try and decide which of
NOTE CONF
the branches we're going down.
Crucially, though, the three choices we have to be able
NOTE CONF
to determine which one we're on with.
Just a single look at cos ours was a single
NOTE CONF
look ahead.
Parsa.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So my three options are V expression and statement.
NOTE CONF
Can I tell with a single look ahead on the
token, not on the scan.
NOTE CONF
Can I tell her the single Look ahead on the
token, Which one I'm in.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I can, because prints always start with prints.
Decorations always start with V and everything else goes under
NOTE CONF
expression.
So if I just all I gotta do is inspect
NOTE CONF
the first token.
I'll know which through which one.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna go down safe.
Good.
NOTE CONF
So I can code those up.
And then this one here, where there's an optional that'll
NOTE CONF
be an if as well and I'll be able to
tell easily whether I'm in that situation or not, because
NOTE CONF
I'll be choosing between a equal symbol and a semicolon
as the next thing that's coming up good.
NOTE CONF
A pasa should be happy.
So as a reminder, we just do expression and print
NOTE CONF
here.
First of all.
NOTE CONF
So I added the variable into my solution because we
got there now.
NOTE CONF
Oh, now, now I'm gonna draw some diagrams.
I'm ready to draw diagrams.
NOTE CONF
I wanna try and remind you of the way the
the pile is working.
NOTE CONF
So first of all, I'm gonna draw the different phases
of the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
I keep saying compiler when I mean interpreter so a
text file comes in.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but let's assume we're not doing interpreter.
We're doing the source code mode.
NOTE CONF
What's the first thing that happens?
You guys know I'm gonna wait for you to tell
NOTE CONF
me it's gonna OK, so this was dot TXT and
what pops out of the scanner A token list and
NOTE CONF
it goes into the almost buzzer.
But I appreciate the attempt and what comes out of
NOTE CONF
the Parsa, the abstract Syntex tree.
OK, and then the buzzer goes into the now's your
NOTE CONF
time and dere and what comes out is the actual
programme whatever that means.
NOTE CONF
I'll put a little spinning thing to represent a programme.
OK, so now let's look harder at each of these
NOTE CONF
parts.
Um well, which parts do we want to look at
NOTE CONF
here.
So we're dealing now with an extension to the plaza.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, because we just realised we need to add, uh,
the statements.
NOTE CONF
And we saw the two different types.
We saw the print statement or the turn out the
NOTE CONF
print, Yeah, print statement or the expression statement.
So I should think to myself that it's the area
NOTE CONF
here that matters.
The things I might have to think about at this
NOTE CONF
point are these things, the inputs, outputs and the Parsa
itself.
NOTE CONF
So the inputs to the powers are.
That's why I made the point when I got to
NOTE CONF
that bit, I'm like, Oh, the token streams already.
Good, because the scanner was doing everything we needed to.
NOTE CONF
So token stream.
I don't have to worry, but that's still coming in,
NOTE CONF
and it's still a token stream.
Um, the A ST is the a ST that I've
NOTE CONF
got sufficient for my purposes.
Let's draw the A ST that we've got, um, to
NOTE CONF
answer that question.
We'll go all the way over here, so we've got
NOTE CONF
some space.
That's why I love drawing an iPad because they give
NOTE CONF
me space.
I used to have to use Bye.
NOTE CONF
So we're drawing the A ST here.
What's the a ST.
NOTE CONF
Well, concretely, I'm just gonna go back to week six
so that we're looking at the right one.
NOTE CONF
Oh, come on.
Did I not include week six?
NOTE CONF
I did.
That is the a ST from week six is Is
NOTE CONF
some is bundled up in this expression dot java that
I created, but it actually came out of.
NOTE CONF
I didn't include the tools in this one.
They didn't include the tools in that one either.
NOTE CONF
Let's go find the tools.
Where the Wow.
NOTE CONF
Um, sorry.
I got sidetracked there.
NOTE CONF
So our a ST is stored in our expression dot
java file.
NOTE CONF
But that fire was originally generated by our, uh, generate
a ST programme.
NOTE CONF
Right now.
Here's my key point.
NOTE CONF
If you're not doing what I'm doing right now, when
you're trying to study com 3000, you got no chance.
NOTE CONF
Right?
There you go.
NOTE CONF
Um, it came from the Generate a ST.
Ah.
NOTE CONF
And so my generate a ST that I had at
that point looked something like we had a bunch of
NOTE CONF
stuff in it.
But the main important part was it had this this
NOTE CONF
definition where I said a binary is an expression left
a token up and an expression right, and I had
NOTE CONF
another one where I said a grouping was an expression
expression, and then I had a bunch of those.
NOTE CONF
I had a literal I had a unary.
That's all I had.
NOTE CONF
And so that's my generator.
A ST knew about those things, and so it was
NOTE CONF
able to generate this little hierarchy, which was the top
expression node and then the binary gripping.
NOTE CONF
I don't know and you know, So that's the hierarchy
I had.
NOTE CONF
That's where it came from, and I'm not gonna put
it in here.
NOTE CONF
But I might put the grammar to help me see
that, but I Maybe I'll keep the grammar on my
NOTE CONF
screen to help me see that myself.
Um, is there a spot in this hierarchy which has
NOTE CONF
gotta be the output of the Parsa for the print
statement and the expression statement?
NOTE CONF
Because when we are when we add a new thing
in the Parsa, maybe we can reuse existing a ST
NOTE CONF
classes to deal with it.
If I had, if I added the ability to pass
NOTE CONF
a new binary operator, I wouldn't have to make a
new a ST note.
NOTE CONF
I'd just use the existing binary.
Uh, do I need is can I use one of
NOTE CONF
these for what I have here, the answer should be
No.
NOTE CONF
These aren't even expressions at all.
They're entirely separate things.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I'm probably gonna need to do something like
create a whole new hierarchy as well.
NOTE CONF
I'm probably gonna want statements to be separate from, and
I'm probably gonna have a print statement, and I probably
NOTE CONF
wanna have an expression statement that inherits from those, right?
Yeah, and the print statement will actually have an expression
NOTE CONF
inside it, won't it?
We'll have a reference back to one of these, and
NOTE CONF
the expression statement will do the same.
We will have a reference back to one of these.
NOTE CONF
So, really, the statement kind of becomes the top, and
then everything else is bundled in there, but we're gonna
NOTE CONF
have to do that.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
So I think that diagram helped me learn something.
And I say to myself, Well, the thing I did
NOTE CONF
to create this, which was up here in generate a
ST, is the thing I'm gonna have to do to
NOTE CONF
generate this.
So I better go back to that, generate a ST
NOTE CONF
and have a look at it.
So I I can't find a version from week five
NOTE CONF
of Generate a ST.
So bear with me.
NOTE CONF
So this is what generate a ST looked like in
week five, but without the variable bit and we can
NOTE CONF
see we had a single function called to find a
ST for creating expressions And it built for us the
NOTE CONF
entire expression class expression Java file and filled in all
the details.
NOTE CONF
We want a separate hierarchy not related to expression.
So we're going to have to define an entirely separate
NOTE CONF
as T the statements.
Um and it'll have an expression statement and a print
NOTE CONF
statement, OK, and a couple of bits I've been playing
with.
NOTE CONF
So that's what he says in the book.
I think he goes over to divine as T and
NOTE CONF
says, Look, I gotta put that in, and I want
to try and join these bits up for you.
NOTE CONF
I really want you to be drawing those diagrams or
thinking that thoughts before you just start reading the text
NOTE CONF
you put here because otherwise you go.
Oh, look, there's the text, and I gotta put it
NOTE CONF
in there and I put the text in there, and
I don't understand why, but it works, OK, so having
NOTE CONF
done that, I know I've got to rerun the, um,
a ST generator because I reminded myself in the diagram.
NOTE CONF
I do that and it spits out two different files.
Now it spits out an expression dot java and a
NOTE CONF
statement dot java Perfect.
I'm gonna use the statement dot java when I'm pasing
NOTE CONF
statements.
I'm gonna use expression dot java when I'm pasing expressions.
NOTE CONF
So let's get back to week five now that we
don't need that.
NOTE CONF
So the powers that we were left with was pausing
single expressions.
NOTE CONF
And so it's output from the PAS phase was an
expression, but we don't want that anymore.
NOTE CONF
We want the pas as the output of the PAS
phase cos the top level of PAS is no longer
NOTE CONF
expression.
The top level of PAS is now a list of
NOTE CONF
statements.
Um, we have to adjust that pas method, and that's
NOTE CONF
what happens here.
So adjusting the pas method requires the pas to output
NOTE CONF
a list of statements instead.
And then the pausing for that list of statements is
NOTE CONF
fairly easy.
It just says keep going, while cos you you told
NOTE CONF
us this when we were doing it.
When you're doing stars in your grammar, you'll do them
NOTE CONF
with a wall loop just while I get until I
get to the end.
NOTE CONF
Keep pausing a statement, and every time I pause a
statement, add it to the existing list of statements and
NOTE CONF
when I run out of statements, return that.
But what does passing each statement look like?
NOTE CONF
Well, as we said before, we've got to look ahead
one to decide if we're doing a print or the
NOTE CONF
V that's not here or the expression I'll jump the
line, which has got them all.
NOTE CONF
I've also got the PAS area in there, which he
hasn't done yet.
NOTE CONF
So I just look one ahead and I say, If
the next thing is a print, then I'm pausing a
NOTE CONF
print statement.
If the next thing is a V, I'm pausing a
NOTE CONF
variable declaration.
If otherwise I'm pasing an expression statement and then just
NOTE CONF
like before with the others.
When I'm charging A when I'm parsing a print statement,
NOTE CONF
I've already matched on the print, so I don't worry
about that.
NOTE CONF
I've now got to pause the expression that's in the
middle then I've got to use up the semicolon and
NOTE CONF
then I've got to give back the answer.
But the answer I'm giving back is one of these
NOTE CONF
statement a ST notes.
That's the a ST note I'm giving back at the
NOTE CONF
PAS phase.
What happened?
NOTE CONF
Gotta find a way to get it all on the
one screen.
NOTE CONF
I know there's some trick you can do with Apple,
but I don't want it out yet.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
We're happy with that passing, so it's just gonna spit
NOTE CONF
back the same.
And look, this print has inside it a value, and
NOTE CONF
we could just be doing this ourselves.
But let's go look at that statement class that got
NOTE CONF
generated for us.
Cos remember we didn't write the statement class that got
NOTE CONF
generated by the A ST generator.
This is where the A ST generator starts to pay
NOTE CONF
off because it put all of this stuff in without
us having to think about it.
NOTE CONF
There's a visitor on statements, and we didn't have to
write it.
NOTE CONF
A ST generate.
Credit it for us.
NOTE CONF
It's got the visitor.
It's got the subst statements, Uh, and the expression one
NOTE CONF
gets constructed by passing in an expression the print.
One gets constructed by passing in an expression, and they
NOTE CONF
both have their visitor methods as required.
And there's the variable, one that I was playing with
NOTE CONF
later.
Nice.
NOTE CONF
And so that's why we have to statement dot print
value that value is in expression.
NOTE CONF
Yes, it is.
So it all lines up.
NOTE CONF
Good.
We're happy.
NOTE CONF
OK, expression, statement, similar thing, Uh, with the expression statement.
Nothing's been consumed yet because I was up here where
NOTE CONF
neither of those matched.
But there's nothing to consume except the expression itself.
NOTE CONF
And then I got to see a semicolon at the
end of it.
NOTE CONF
And then I store that expression and expression statement when
I did the variable Declaration.
NOTE CONF
The V keyword's been consumed with its match, but I've
got to find the identifier.
NOTE CONF
So we're doing this line now.
Well, we're doing both these lines.
NOTE CONF
The V keyword's been consumed, so I gotta grab the
identifier token and then potentially grab an equals expression token
NOTE CONF
and then definitely grab a semicolon.
So I do that I grab the identifier token.
NOTE CONF
If I see an equals, then I grab an expression
for the back half.
NOTE CONF
I definitely grab a semicolon and my final output is
the statement variable I created noting that because the initialise
NOTE CONF
a part of the variable is optional, it might be
null.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna put a null in there.
If the person didn't initialise their variable declaration, this is
NOTE CONF
a chance for us to do better.
I didn't put it in the workshops this week, but
NOTE CONF
I was tempted to, um remembering that Nystrom wrote this
for an maximum compatibility.
NOTE CONF
He's not using some of the later Java features like
optionals.
NOTE CONF
This should be an optional value, not a value that
can potentially be nulled If you remember back to 2000.
NOTE CONF
Uh, refactoring this to use an optional would be a
fun experiment.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll do that this afternoon.
OK, And then it just goes on like before.
NOTE CONF
Um, each expression is definitely inequality.
Inequality is definitely in comparison in comparison.
NOTE CONF
Da da, da, da.
So on and so forth just backs out to expression.
NOTE CONF
We've got all the passing, We need questions.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
OK, now we gotta execute them.
So let's remind ourselves of how execution works in this
NOTE CONF
system.
There's something I left out in my diagram.
NOTE CONF
First time I drew them but I'll draw it now
if I can draw small enough.
NOTE CONF
I was drawing it like this before, right?
We got visitors at a visitor, ClA or visitor interface
NOTE CONF
inside expression.
And there's another visitor interface inside statement.
NOTE CONF
So recall that a couple of different bits and pieces
we had in our system were done using visitors.
NOTE CONF
One thing we did with a visitor was print the
A ST with a visitor.
NOTE CONF
And when we did that, we had a class that
was a AST visitor or a ST printer or something
NOTE CONF
and what that means.
So you make that class, let's call it the print
NOTE CONF
visitor or something.
I should look at my code to see what it
NOTE CONF
really is, but it implements the expression dot visitor.
It implements that little interface we had up there.
NOTE CONF
Can you see what we're gonna have to do now?
We can't just print an a ST with an expression
NOTE CONF
visitor anymore because part of the A ST might be
a statement.
NOTE CONF
So we've got to implement the statement visitor as well.
But this is one of the big advantages of visitors.
NOTE CONF
They compose like this.
Um, they don't interact.
NOTE CONF
OK, so anything we?
Anything we did with a visitor now has to be
NOTE CONF
done with an expression visitor and a statement visitor if
we want to keep using it.
NOTE CONF
So what else?
You used to visit it?
NOTE CONF
Well, the entirety of the interpreter was written as a
visitor.
NOTE CONF
You really should think that anything we do on this
a ST gets done at a visitor, and we printed
NOTE CONF
it.
We did it as a visitor when we interpreted it,
NOTE CONF
we did it as a visitor.
So our interpreter now has to visit both statements and
NOTE CONF
expressions, and that's what he's doing there.
The interpreter just has to be improved to now, remembering
NOTE CONF
that the visitors told us what the return type of
the visitor was.
NOTE CONF
So expression used object because we didn't know what expressions
returned.
NOTE CONF
But visitors we know on statements.
We know for sure they don't return anything.
NOTE CONF
Statements don't return things.
They do things.
NOTE CONF
So it's void and it has to be the capital
V void because of the way generics works.
NOTE CONF
Um, but visiting statements is quite simple.
Really.
NOTE CONF
If you're visiting one of these expression statements, just evaluate
the expression, which is the same as visiting the expression
NOTE CONF
and which are now.
If you're visiting a print statement and there's gonna be
NOTE CONF
one expression inside that, evaluate it and just print it
on the screen, he's peasy that it a little bit
NOTE CONF
more going on when you wanna do variable declaration, because
when you visit a variable declaration, you have to create
NOTE CONF
a new entry in the environment, and the environment is
next week's concept.
NOTE CONF
But for us to complete our interpreter, we have to
fill in the the visit statement for the variable declaration.
NOTE CONF
Um, and in the workshops, I've suggested you just do
that with a null like an empty function.
NOTE CONF
But it's left for the workshops.
They have to make a few other adjustments in the
NOTE CONF
interpreter because it doesn't work on objects anymore.
It works on lists of statements, and we have to
NOTE CONF
get into worrying about runtime errors again.
So it try, try and catch because there could be
NOTE CONF
something go wrong in the execution of statements.
And when we catch that, we'll call out to the
NOTE CONF
locks runtime error.
And just like with the PSA, which you explored in
NOTE CONF
the workshops last week because PSAs are recursive calls to
functions, Um that it's better to use exceptions to unroll
NOTE CONF
that back to one point rather than just to return
errors.
NOTE CONF
Uh, because when you recursively call as long as it's
the last thing, the unrolling automatically happens.
NOTE CONF
But if something tries to happen after the recursive call,
the unrolling breaks and let me try and explain that
NOTE CONF
I think that's interesting.
Well, I I it was probably done in the workshops,
NOTE CONF
but I'll do it again now just quickly because understanding
why we're using exceptions is not other things.
NOTE CONF
So you know when you do recursive calls, let's call.
Let's call this function Foo and Foo does A and
NOTE CONF
then Foo again.
So when we execute that we execute Fu let get
NOTE CONF
a and let me execute Fu again Let me execute
a Let me execute Fu again Let me execute a
NOTE CONF
execute few again So if something goes wrong and Fu
just stops, we can happily just stop that food which
NOTE CONF
immediately stops this food which immediately stops this flu which
immediately stops this food and all the error handling works.
NOTE CONF
But if our foo was Fu a Foo B and
we try the same thing, we get food which calls
NOTE CONF
a food B and Fu calls a foo B and
foals a mhm.
NOTE CONF
Now, something goes wrong on this food.
We're still going to try and run B, and then
NOTE CONF
we're gonna unroll that and we're still gonna try and
run B.
NOTE CONF
And then we're gonna unroll that and we're still gonna
try and run B.
NOTE CONF
And we shouldn't be trying to run B because something
went wrong.
NOTE CONF
So the trick when you do an exception, instead it
just throws straight back up until it finds a tri
NOTE CONF
block.
Doesn't try to do anything else much safer.
NOTE CONF
So when you're doing recursive calls, better to use exceptions
or not.
NOTE CONF
But then once we find the exception at the top
of the recursive call, we can just bump it off
NOTE CONF
to Lock's error reporting, which is what we do.
OK, and then there's an execute.
NOTE CONF
Um, executing any statement involves just putting it into the
Vira, and the rest is just bits and pieces.
NOTE CONF
So then that works.
So the next thing he talks about is the kind
NOTE CONF
of design decisions around variables.
So, uh, I've already had that in my code, so
NOTE CONF
we don't have to go through his code on it,
but maybe we will.
NOTE CONF
A variable declaration in, um, locks brings a new variable
into existence.
NOTE CONF
The syntax he's got for it is V.
Then identify it, then optionally equals the expression.
NOTE CONF
And then you can use that, Um, what does it
say here?
NOTE CONF
Clauses and control flow statements.
I think that then a nose branch, I reach a
NOTE CONF
single statement.
But that statement is not allowed to be one that
NOTE CONF
declares a name.
This is that we could allow the ladder, but it's
NOTE CONF
confusing.
What is the scope of that beverage variable?
NOTE CONF
Does it persist after the statement?
If so, what is its value on data on Monday?
NOTE CONF
The variable exist on other days.
Code like this is weird, so Java disallows it.
NOTE CONF
It's as if there's two levels of precedence for statements.
Some places where a statement is allowed allow any kind
NOTE CONF
of statement.
Others allow only the higher precedent statements that don't declare
NOTE CONF
names.
Oh yeah, I That grammar I was showing you is
NOTE CONF
a simplified grammar.
Yeah, let's talk about this.
NOTE CONF
So from what we've seen, the grammar I was showing
you before for my simplified variable grammar works just fine.
NOTE CONF
But in the text.
Instead, he goes with a slightly more complicated grammar.
NOTE CONF
So I'll switch over and draw mine out and I'll
explain the difference.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, colour do we wanna go?
Let's go back to yellow.
NOTE CONF
I like yellow.
Oh, stop that.
NOTE CONF
Stop that!
So I said that a programme is a list of
NOTE CONF
statements and end of file in the statement is a
print.
NOTE CONF
Hey, man.
Oh, I'm giving things different names.
NOTE CONF
Be consistent is a print statement or a expression statement
or a viable declaration statement.
NOTE CONF
And then on I went, Yep.
But the suggestion in the book is that it should
NOTE CONF
be a programme is a list of declaration style in
the file, and the declaration is either a variable declaration
NOTE CONF
or a normal statement had a normal statement.
Is a print statement or an expression statement OK, so
NOTE CONF
slightly different.
I know it's impossible to read when it's that small,
NOTE CONF
but, um uh, I gotta switch this down.
You saw me type right at Vega, so maybe it
NOTE CONF
makes sense.
Um, come on, come on.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
And now we can see the two side by side.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so those are the two possible grammars to express
the same thing.
NOTE CONF
What's?
And we gotta go back a week or two.
NOTE CONF
The one we looking at pausing What's the difference that
in these two grammars, Yeah, the right one is opening
NOTE CONF
up in two parts and yeah, yeah, that's true.
And that the strings that this grammar produces are ID
NOTE CONF
uh, the two grammars produced are identical as long as
the things underneath the dot, dot dot are identical and
NOTE CONF
the programmes that the grammars accept what are they identical?
They're identical right now, as far as we're concerned.
NOTE CONF
Um, yeah, when the dot dot dots are the same
right now in our system, the the strings produced and
NOTE CONF
the strings passed are identical.
Why would we choose one over the other?
NOTE CONF
There's no good reason at this point, but what the
text introduces is the idea of when it is going
NOTE CONF
to be important.
So what does the breakup do if I do a
NOTE CONF
pause of a simple programme, So I'll do a part
of the programme we're gonna do?
NOTE CONF
Um, the program's gonna be just a simple lux programme
that says, Come on for semicolon simplest programme I can
NOTE CONF
come up with under the left system.
It's I first look at the programme production and then
NOTE CONF
I realised it has to be a statement production and
it has to be just one of them.
NOTE CONF
And then I realised that the statement production has to
be an expression statement and then I go into the
NOTE CONF
dot dot dots to fix it on this side.
I see that I've got a programme and the only
NOTE CONF
thing that can be is a single declaration and it's
definitely not a var decal.
NOTE CONF
So it's gonna have to be a statement and it's
gonna have to be an expression statement and now I'm
NOTE CONF
into the dot dot dots OK, so the only difference
was that there's an extra part in the derivation here
NOTE CONF
is I had to go through declaration to get to
statement, to realise that it was an expression statement and
NOTE CONF
on the go.
Now let's look at the next one.
NOTE CONF
So the next one is VX So same thing on
the left hand side that passes as programme to single
NOTE CONF
statement and this time it's to a var Deco Oh,
I've got to put V Deco over here.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Oh, no, I don't because my they goes up there
NOTE CONF
N and then doing my own work.
Um, programme to statement Statement to vico dot dot dot
NOTE CONF
On the right hand side, it's programme the declaration to
Vical.
NOTE CONF
OK, so for this one, I just had an extra
statement declaration in there.
NOTE CONF
Whatever.
It didn't seem to make a difference.
NOTE CONF
But on this one, I've actually got a separate different
structure for the for the derivation.
NOTE CONF
And what that allows me to do in my Parsa
is I can tell the difference between these two statements.
NOTE CONF
Now, if I ever need to treat these kinds of
statements differently to these kinds of statements, I know that
NOTE CONF
those ones will always start with statement and these ones
will always start with declaration.
NOTE CONF
So I've kind of put a flag on there to
help me work out.
NOTE CONF
Uh, which one am I?
And what he says in the book is that matters
NOTE CONF
for some productions we're gonna do later.
Later on, we're gonna have, um And if statement and
NOTE CONF
an if statement is gonna have an expression, so it's
gonna be something like if expression followed by statement that's
NOTE CONF
trying to represent if X is less than four print
OK, Yeah, but he specifically for the single line F
NOTE CONF
statements, which, you know, we like single line FS.
We made a point about it in one of the
NOTE CONF
early lectures.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Single line FS are good.
Ruby gives us a good version for a single line.
NOTE CONF
If it's nonsensical to say so, He's basically saying, I
don't want to allow this one.
NOTE CONF
I do want to allow any other statement, so I
have to put in my Parsa some little flag to
NOTE CONF
tell me when I've got something that's actually one of
these special kind of statements that don't belong absolutely everywhere.
NOTE CONF
A statement belongs so all of that was by way
of saying, because they need to be treated differently in
NOTE CONF
the past, Just like when I did precedent, I needed
to treat some parts differently to other parts.
NOTE CONF
I've got to give them the separate production for themselves.
So I do.
NOTE CONF
Um, so that's why his grandma looks like that.
Uh, and I like this is me.
NOTE CONF
And I'm reminding you, I mean, we're laboriously going over
something from three weeks ago because this middle part of
NOTE CONF
the course, we're wanting to really settle on those ideas
and come back and see them over and over and
NOTE CONF
get more comfortable with them and remind.
Okay, So the last part of allowing, um, the last
NOTE CONF
part of the passing of variables that he includes here
is he He says, I'm gonna start to allow variables
NOTE CONF
to appear in expressions as well.
Sure, we don't know how to evaluate them yet, but
NOTE CONF
let's at least allow them.
So I can print X instead of just print five.
NOTE CONF
And I got to think to myself, What does a
variable act like So I can work out where to
NOTE CONF
put it in the in the pazza.
And the variable really is very much like a literal
NOTE CONF
That just doesn't I just don't know the value for
sure.
NOTE CONF
I've got to look up the memory to find the
value, so I probably want it going exactly where literals
NOTE CONF
go and that's in the primary part.
And if I do that, things do work out exactly
NOTE CONF
the way I want them to.
So I was looking for the literals true, false and
NOTE CONF
nil.
I was looking for the literals of numbers and strings.
NOTE CONF
I also put the parenthesis expressions down here because that
was my most highest precedence operator.
NOTE CONF
Um, but this is the place where I put identifier
for variable that's grabbing anything that's a variable.
NOTE CONF
And that's why those two go into the A ST
generator as well.
NOTE CONF
So that extra one goes into the A ST generator.
Um, we're generating expression statements, print statements, uh, variable declaration
NOTE CONF
statements.
That's this one.
NOTE CONF
That's the variable declaration statement, not the variable use statement.
I'm gonna make a big point this week about separating
NOTE CONF
variable declaration from variable use and you'll sit there going,
Oh, that's boring.
NOTE CONF
That's obvious.
But it's quite important, Um, verbal declaration.
NOTE CONF
So one of the ones up there, where does variable
use go in the a ST generator?
NOTE CONF
Because this step here, we just added a new thing
to our plaza.
NOTE CONF
And like I showed you before, when we are adding
things to our plaza, we need to think about this
NOTE CONF
entire green zone.
So what happens?
NOTE CONF
The variables were already happily being picked up by the
token in the token stream.
NOTE CONF
We could make an adjustment to our Parsa, but do
we need to make an adjustment to our A ST?
NOTE CONF
Well, let's go over at this point We've got statements
with print statements and expression statements, and by now I've
NOTE CONF
also added on the variable the variable declaration statement.
And I think the literal it's going in the Pars
NOTE CONF
are where expressions are.
So it's gonna have to go in the a SD
NOTE CONF
where the expressions are.
It's definitely not binary.
NOTE CONF
Don't think it's uni cos Uni's got one argument.
It's not a grouping, OK, think of it as a
NOTE CONF
literal.
Maybe, maybe not.
NOTE CONF
I got choices in in short, and the choice that's
made in the book is to not treat it as
NOTE CONF
a literal um, and le let's just go through that
decision a little bit.
NOTE CONF
So I'm sitting here thinking I'm passing my variables.
Where are they gonna end up in my a ST
NOTE CONF
and I go and check exactly what a literal looks
like.
NOTE CONF
I'm doing this on my computer.
I know you can't see it, but I'm going and
NOTE CONF
looking exactly what a literal looks like.
And I see that a literal takes an object value.
NOTE CONF
So when I construct the little rules, I have to
give it a value of type object, and I think
NOTE CONF
to myself when I'm constructing a variable.
I'm gonna have to put what could I put in
NOTE CONF
for value?
What's your time?
NOTE CONF
If I'm constructing a variable, what do I put in
for value?
NOTE CONF
This context is spring.
I understand the question.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Yeah, I think maybe I've not represented the question.
NOTE CONF
Well, rephrase my question.
So the Parsa is currently running through, and the Parsa
NOTE CONF
has gotten to the point where it's just discovered.
It's been working its way through that primary thing.
NOTE CONF
The path is doing this section primary, and we know
that when the path sees a true, it gives back
NOTE CONF
a literal with the value.
True, when it sees a false, it gives back a
NOTE CONF
literal with the value false.
When it sees a nil, it gives a literal with
NOTE CONF
the value nil.
When it sees a number, it gives a literal and
NOTE CONF
puts that number in there.
When it sees a string, Literal puts the string in
NOTE CONF
there.
When it sees expression, it gives back a grouping with
NOTE CONF
the expression in there when it sees an identifier.
If I make it, give back a literal what's the
NOTE CONF
value it's gonna put in there?
Yeah, I have.
NOTE CONF
I have a question.
Why is it that why?
NOTE CONF
Good question.
I'll come back to it.
NOTE CONF
Yep, identifiable at run time.
It will.
NOTE CONF
But where at pas time, which is before anything's run
now is the only option we have.
NOTE CONF
Basically, we don't know what the value of that variable
is.
NOTE CONF
In fact, the variable of that variable is gonna change
constantly during the programme.
NOTE CONF
And so the fact that a literal requires a value
probably is the reason we don't want to use a
NOTE CONF
literal, um cool.
And in your question, why is it identified there when
NOTE CONF
we're passing variables?
Because identifier, which covers both.
NOTE CONF
Just a reminder, identify in our context.
An identifier, I think, is anything that starts with a
NOTE CONF
lower case alpha, numeric or alpha and then includes or
just includes sorry starts with an alpha and then has
NOTE CONF
any number of alpha numerics after it.
Um, that covers us for variable names, and it covers
NOTE CONF
us for function names, and it covers us for parameter
names.
NOTE CONF
And it covers us for class names in the locks
language, and this is common in most programme languages.
NOTE CONF
So the idea of unidentified is that token that qualifies
for those rules starts with a letter and then only
NOTE CONF
has letters, numbers and underscores or whatever.
After it, Um, and this place that it slots into
NOTE CONF
the pas tree is those four or five different places.
So if we're looking for a variable, we can just
NOTE CONF
look for an identifier.
And it'll be true at exactly the same time as
NOTE CONF
the variable is true because they're the same thing.
Makes sense.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Yeah, of course.
Alright, so we throw out the idea of using the
NOTE CONF
existing literal a ST node, and we tell ourselves we're
gonna need a new variable, a ST node, and so
NOTE CONF
we do it.
What field is the variable a ST node gonna have?
NOTE CONF
Well, the thing that defines the variable is its identifier
in our case, you know, X or whatever.
NOTE CONF
Um, and the book actually points out, there's a couple
of options here.
NOTE CONF
Um, we could store the original string that came from
it.
NOTE CONF
We could store the token that we found when we
passed.
NOTE CONF
Um, those are the two options we have.
Uh, they end up going with the string because of
NOTE CONF
the way they build their environments.
But as you can see, they're both perfectly fine Well,
NOTE CONF
the other part is, why wouldn't we use the token?
If you remember what's bundled up inside the token is
NOTE CONF
the line number.
Um, that might be useful.
NOTE CONF
It might not.
Uh, the book argues for why it's not useful, but
NOTE CONF
it's a decision that's made during the compilation process during
the comp writing of the compiler.
NOTE CONF
Alrighty.
So we've got we're gonna need a new a ST
NOTE CONF
type to cover that.
Oh, no, he goes with token.
NOTE CONF
Ah, there you go.
He goes with token, so it keeps the line number.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a variable goes into the expression part of
the A SD generator and its single, uh, argument is
NOTE CONF
a token.
And then we got to run the A ST generator
NOTE CONF
again, which we do, and we get the new visitor
and off we go The other reason I like my
NOTE CONF
diagram here is because by drawing things in orange, I
realise, Hey, if every time I update the a ST,
NOTE CONF
I've gotta update everything.
That's a visitor on the a ST Because every time
NOTE CONF
I update the a ST, I'm gonna change the interface
of those two visitors, and that's gonna change the number
NOTE CONF
of methods I have to override.
OK, so I've probably got to go and rewrite my
NOTE CONF
print a ST, and I've probably gotta go and rewrite
my interpreter visitor.
NOTE CONF
And that's the bit where we go.
Yeah, I don't know how to write the interpreter for
NOTE CONF
a visitor for a variable yet because I don't know
about environments.
NOTE CONF
Would you like that for next week?
OK, so what we're gonna do for the rest of
NOTE CONF
today is we're going to muck about with that week
seven code.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna make those adjustments.
Uh, make a copy of it.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna put some code in and just play around.
Let's put this back up as a while.
NOTE CONF
I get, uh, and let's check if anyone's asking any
questions online.
NOTE CONF
No, they are not.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So here's my process for getting a fresh version.
I go CP minus R.
NOTE CONF
And by the way, if you're using the docker thing,
all these whether you're on Windows or Linux, all these
NOTE CONF
work for you because the docker is always Linux.
Um, CP minus, uh, week seven into variants.
NOTE CONF
I gotta make the directory first.
Uh, variants.
NOTE CONF
What should we do?
What's what's the interesting thing you wanna do with locks?
NOTE CONF
Just got something to do with statements.
Nothing.
NOTE CONF
Mm.
Well, I'll do a print line as well as a
NOTE CONF
print.
It's not that interesting.
NOTE CONF
His print already puts a new line at the end,
so well, his print already puts a new line at
NOTE CONF
the end.
So maybe we should adjust it so it doesn't and
NOTE CONF
add a print line.
Uh, yeah, it's a good idea, so we'll call it
NOTE CONF
print line.
OK, Hopefully, I now go over and look at variants,
NOTE CONF
and I see there's my new variant and it's the
full.
NOTE CONF
But I copied out the classes.
That was a bit of a waste of time, but
NOTE CONF
OK, now I've gotta go into there and let's just
open up one of them for the fun of it.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I go in there and I do patrol shift
desk and I need to change syntax.
NOTE CONF
Week five.
I need to change weeks 0.7 because I just put
NOTE CONF
this in a package called Variance seven plus print line,
so it's gotta be Varian 0.7 plus print line.
NOTE CONF
That's not doesn't get there, so weeks 0.7 is being
converted into variant seven.
NOTE CONF
Do Sprint line.
The files to include adjust the files in weeks.
NOTE CONF
Slash Sorry, adjust the files.
Invariance slash seven plus print line.
NOTE CONF
Ta da!
And is it finding them all?
NOTE CONF
It's weeks 0.7 not weeks slash seven.
And there we go.
NOTE CONF
So it's finding all the ones I want, and I
pressed the replace button and it replaces 13 occurrences.
NOTE CONF
And there you go.
You just saw that it updated it.
NOTE CONF
And so now I should be out of jev like
that.
NOTE CONF
Who errors Method does not override or implement a method
from a super type.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
I guess I left Week seven in a broken state,
NOTE CONF
so let's go fix those.
So let's look at what these errors are saying.
NOTE CONF
These errors are saying, um, method does not override or
implement a method from a super type override in a
NOTE CONF
ST printer 0.8.
And that means I put override there when there was
NOTE CONF
actually nothing to override.
So I'm that could be an error from my a
NOTE CONF
ST generation, So I'm gonna redo my a ST generation.
I think it is.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna jab back Variant seven plus two star
dot Java, and then I'm gonna Java Varian seven plus
NOTE CONF
tools to generate a ST.
And then I got to tell it what directory it
NOTE CONF
goes into, which is Variance seven plus Nano presenter.
So I just regenerated my expression file, which is this
NOTE CONF
one here and now I'll try Kani again and Mr
at Tierra.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's go Look, my a SD printer.
What?
NOTE CONF
It didn't get the update.
Ah, so my search and replace Sometimes I use the
NOTE CONF
wrong syntax and I don't get the um no.
Why didn't I get that updated?
NOTE CONF
I don't know why they didn't update.
That should be bury and start seven a print line.
NOTE CONF
Because that's my new package.
Because that's my new directory.
NOTE CONF
And now it works.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
So now I've got a copy of Week seven.
I haven't actually made any of my changes.
NOTE CONF
So what are the changes I wanna make?
Let's get out.
NOTE CONF
My not doing anything without drawing diagrams ever again.
So I've decided that I want print to operate differently,
NOTE CONF
and I want to add print line.
Well, there's the magic word operate.
NOTE CONF
Any changes to the operation of an argument has to
happen in the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
So let's go to the interpreter.
You're not finding it very nicely.
NOTE CONF
So in the interpreter, I know my outline's not working
here because I don't have my, um, my Java stuff
NOTE CONF
plugged in properly in the Interpreter.
I'm going to find the visit expression statement, which is
NOTE CONF
not interesting.
Visit VA Statement Visit print statement.
NOTE CONF
So here's the one I need to adjust.
Currently, the visit print statement is doing a system without
NOTE CONF
print line on the string of I.
I want it to do just a print on the
NOTE CONF
string of I Sorry I to OK, I'm in my
interpreter class and I scroll down until I find the
NOTE CONF
right visitor and it's the visit print statement, and I've
just got to get rid of this print line and
NOTE CONF
change it to a print.
But having done that, I should then also test that
NOTE CONF
it's doing what I want to do.
So hopefully I've put a bunch of locks programmes in
NOTE CONF
all in in each directory.
Um, that looks like one little test for me.
NOTE CONF
What do I expect to have happen if print acts
differently now?
NOTE CONF
Well, I expect, um, that it won't go to a
new line at the end of the print.
NOTE CONF
So let's try Java variance seven locks and I'm gonna
pass up the file variance seven print expression dot locks,
NOTE CONF
which was that one right there.
And I can't notice a difference.
NOTE CONF
There looks exactly Oh, because they didn't compile and run
again.
NOTE CONF
I better compile it again.
And now on the end.
NOTE CONF
And there you go.
It is different.
NOTE CONF
See, they printed it but didn't jump to a new
line.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I have successfully made that change.
Now, let's add the, um Let's add the print line.
NOTE CONF
So back up to the print line.
Print line's gonna have to be a new keyword.
NOTE CONF
You You should have just zoom this in earlier.
Sorry about that, dude.
NOTE CONF
I know.
Hopeless, um, for print line.
NOTE CONF
I'm actually gonna have to touch everything along the way
here because I'd attach the source file.
NOTE CONF
Yes, I will.
I have to make new tests.
NOTE CONF
Scanner currently doesn't look for a print line token.
Hazer doesn't know what to do with a print line
NOTE CONF
token.
An interpreter doesn't know.
NOTE CONF
Well, will the interpreter have to do anything?
Probably.
NOTE CONF
Um if we think ahead, will we be able to
use one of our existing A ST nodes.
NOTE CONF
Yes, the Unary should be just fine.
I think print goes under unary, right?
NOTE CONF
No.
Prier's understatement.
NOTE CONF
So there's a print statement here.
Can I make use of the print statement?
NOTE CONF
Maybe I could put a bully in to say whether
it's they're like inheritance wells of R, it's called, so
NOTE CONF
that was a good suggestion.
I could do this right?
NOTE CONF
That's what you're suggesting.
That's a good design idea, but it actually doesn't fit
NOTE CONF
with my current system because this setup gets generated by
the A ST generator and the A ST generator's not
NOTE CONF
that smart.
Um, I can extend my a ST generator.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I'm gonna have a choice here at the
A ST phase as to whether I want to make
NOTE CONF
a new print line version or I want to adjust
print so that it can do both because we saw
NOTE CONF
how literal can do a bunch of different things.
It's possible for print to do a bunch of different
NOTE CONF
things, but we just gotta maybe give it an extra
parameter to say whether it's a print or a print
NOTE CONF
line.
So maybe that's a true or a false that goes
NOTE CONF
in, so we will have to make some adjustment, But
I think we'll probably still use the same node.
NOTE CONF
Probably.
Alright, but let's get back.
NOTE CONF
First things first.
The scanner.
NOTE CONF
So we remember the scanner print is gonna be a
straight up keyword, so I can just put it in
NOTE CONF
my keyword list, But here, I can see I'm not
gonna have this print line token type.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Oh, you gotta yell out next time I gotta go
to my scanner and just add this line and maybe
NOTE CONF
spell it right.
Uh, I'm not gonna have this print line token type,
NOTE CONF
so I better go over to token type.
Uh, you didn't show me the one.
NOTE CONF
I want evidence, and I have to add the print
line in.
NOTE CONF
I might as well put it next to the print.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
It's in the right spot print line.
So now I got that one added.
NOTE CONF
So that's gonna get the scanner running.
But when I get to the Parsa, I'm gonna wonder
NOTE CONF
where it should go.
So the pas are here is now potentially gonna see
NOTE CONF
a print line that it doesn't know what to do
with So what do I wanna do?
NOTE CONF
Well, over here, I want to say that it could
be a print statement or it could be a print
NOTE CONF
line statement and that there's not much difference between those
two except that.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that seems simple enough.
So now I'm gonna have to go down and adjust
NOTE CONF
the now.
This is a comment.
NOTE CONF
I didn't need to write this in, but I like
to keep it up to date because I find it
NOTE CONF
much easier to think about the code after I've written
the simpler version, which is the grammar.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna have to update statement, and I'm gonna
have to create the new one of these.
NOTE CONF
So let's go find statement.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
I can see that I've got a if match print,
so I'm gonna make it a if match print line.
NOTE CONF
So if this token you're seeing is a print line,
then do a print line statement and then I can
NOTE CONF
go find the print statement and copy that.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
Everything else is gonna stay exactly the same.
But here I realise I can't just spit out the
NOTE CONF
exact same print a ST note or I won't be
able to tell the difference at execution time.
NOTE CONF
That's where my choice kicks in.
I can either build myself a new print line statement
NOTE CONF
type, or I can maybe extend the existing one to
say whether there's a new line being printed or not
NOTE CONF
at the end.
OK, so that one would be false and that one
NOTE CONF
would be true.
Yeah, and I like this idea better, So I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
go over and regenerate my a ST nodes to do
this instead.
NOTE CONF
So what I've done there is I've added an extra
argument to the print a ST node.
NOTE CONF
So I jump back over to the tool generator and
I go find where I define the print one and
NOTE CONF
instead of it just having an expression.
It's also got a Boolean new line to tell me
NOTE CONF
whether there's going to be a new line at the
end of it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the last thing I'm gonna have to do
is go back to my interpreter because my interpreter is
NOTE CONF
operating on that thing and back where I changed this
print statement, um, I'm gonna have to do two different
NOTE CONF
things, depending on what the statement has.
If statement if the statement does have a new line.
NOTE CONF
Well said, See, then I do the print line else.
I do the not print line version and I think
NOTE CONF
that'll work.
So I think I've touched everything I need to to
NOTE CONF
make it work.
So I run the first I jab at the what
NOTE CONF
the heck, Let's clear that out.
First I jab back the tool, Choose that one, then
NOTE CONF
I java the tool.
Then I jak the code.
NOTE CONF
Oh, and then let me do it.
But now I've got to test the code.
NOTE CONF
So I've gotta have a test case if I just
run it on the last one.
NOTE CONF
I ran it on.
I'll get the 5.75 thing before, but I need a
NOTE CONF
version where I'm able to test both.
So I've got statements.
NOTE CONF
I might as well use them.
Let's do print line.
NOTE CONF
Hi.
I don't need the brackets and then print five.
NOTE CONF
So I expect the high new line and then the
thing and then not a new line and then print
NOTE CONF
there.
So I'm expecting to see no new line of one.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Print the line.
NOTE CONF
All right, let's run.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
It worked.
I got the new line after the high newly line
NOTE CONF
after the 5.75 and a new line after the there.
Here we go.
NOTE CONF
We've added a new expression to our language.
End to end.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a preview for next week we are doing.
We've made it down to environments.
NOTE CONF
At this point in your workshops, we're focusing on this
understanding the code as a whole as well as making
NOTE CONF
some adjustments.
There'll be another statement for you to add in your
NOTE CONF
workshops.
It's an exit statement.
NOTE CONF
Then next week we'll go on and we'll do the
environment section.
NOTE CONF
So it's all down through environments, um, global variables the
different ways you might I implement assignment cos we've done,
NOTE CONF
um, assignment during a declaration, but we haven't done assignment
outside of a declaration yet.
NOTE CONF
Then we go through how you would do assignment or
should do assignment at the various oat O options because
NOTE CONF
they are different semantics.
And then we discuss how environments or nested environments help
NOTE CONF
us implement scope.
You haven't seen it yet, but in, um, in locks,
NOTE CONF
you can just open a curly brace to start a
new scope.
NOTE CONF
And you know that in statically typed languages.
Well, in most of the languages Lexi.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Lexical scoped languages.
NOTE CONF
Uh, if you hide a variable, then it's hidden.
It doesn't disappear, but it's hidden.
NOTE CONF
So we we look at how we do nested environments
to implement that.
NOTE CONF
And that's that nesting and sharing so you can see
why I split it up.
NOTE CONF
So I did a busy week next week.
Maybe.
NOTE CONF
Could have gone a little bit further this week.
Um And then after that, it's the first day of
NOTE CONF
Scala and Scala is the most exciting of all these
languages.
NOTE CONF
So do enjoy Skala.
Any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Anything appearing over here?
Nothing.
NOTE CONF
OK, thank you.
I'll catch you around.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I, I get blood.
Yeah, that.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, they're very hard to my very point you want.
Uh, yeah, I'm gonna get that three months.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
This is just a question.
NOTE CONF
Those changes.
Um, one thing I kind of noticed is that for
NOTE CONF
both print and print line, they generally belong to a
class of uterine consumers.
NOTE CONF
And it's more generally, there, entire, entire family if you
get a little print statements.
NOTE CONF
So just as a design decision, rather than using a
would it be a worthwhile decision to maybe have a
NOTE CONF
hash map that binds some sort of enumeration to a
uterine consumer function.
NOTE CONF
And then, rather than for each print statement you might
have in your language rather than doing those checks, you
NOTE CONF
can just match it to the hash map and then
evaluate that function if you understand where I'm coming, Uh,
NOTE CONF
you can do that.
But I think ultimately that it is a visit.
NOTE CONF
OK, so what you'd really do there?
And I can, um a ST?
NOTE CONF
No, but there might be there might be a reason
why you all to the A ST?
NOTE CONF
No, but the other part of it is that prints
and print lines done his way here.
NOTE CONF
They really are dysfunctional.
So ultimately, you implement functions and how they deal with
NOTE CONF
their parameters.
And then you won't have to think about any of
NOTE CONF
that.
That's great.
NOTE CONF
Thank you so much.
OK, so I'm looking for an assignment, and I'm a
NOTE CONF
little confused with this section in particular, starting point like,
is this telling us what we're supposed to If we
NOTE CONF
were if we were following the textbook, is this telling
us what we're supposed to replace?
NOTE CONF
So I went through that at the last week.
OK?
NOTE CONF
Because like, OK, so see, I was I was thinking
that might be the case, because, like, I I'm just
NOTE CONF
not sure how to get it through.
That means, um line 12 becomes a add a new
NOTE CONF
line and it becomes line 13.
So line goes in line 15, change the line and
NOTE CONF
it becomes line 16.
Line this line this line Line 18, Change line 1923.
NOTE CONF
Take out this line and put in these lines.
OK, so and then this is this delete.
NOTE CONF
Delete those lines and then there's AC line.
OK, just change in.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a is basically if you look at if
you look at the locks programme and just look for
NOTE CONF
where that exists, you'll see that that's what you want
to put it in.
NOTE CONF
That exists.
You put that the line numbers are less important, but
NOTE CONF
they all size.
OK, thanks, I.
NOTE CONF
I got a question, um, for a special consideration.
Uh, who do I need to, uh, message?
NOTE CONF
Because I'm in New Zealand the week, OK, just asking,
um, 13th of the Friday next week.
NOTE CONF
Uh, 23rd, 22.
Yeah, I like 10 days, So I Yeah, yeah, Saturday
NOTE CONF
or Sunday.
I can.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Um OK, I'm gonna try it then.
And I had another question that I forgot what I
NOTE CONF
wanted to ask you Doesn't matter.
Then we have to set supplement to get on the
NOTE CONF
down is going to choose.
But anyway, I need to see if I get 77%
NOTE CONF
1st, but I think I will be.
I think I should be able to get it.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'll have a look.
I need to that one too, man out of if
NOTE CONF
we want to look at is the OK three I
100.
NOTE CONF
Got it.
Do it.
NOTE CONF